المضخات التي تعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي ،
برامج إدارة ثاني أكسيد الكربون لأنظمة ضغط الهواء المتطورة ، هذه هي
بعض التقنيات التي تشكل مستقبل وزراء
الطاقة
، اجتمع كبار الرؤساء التنفيذيين والقادة في
صناعة النفط والغاز هنا
في مؤتمر تكنولوجيا الغاز في دبي
لمناقشة الأفكار والابتكارات التي
تحدث ثورة  الصناعة على مدار العقد المقبل
، وهناك هدف مشترك واحد يصبح
مستدامًا أثناء إنتاج الطاقة التي
يريدها العالم
ويحتاجها ، بيكر هيوز في
طليعة الابتكار التكنولوجي في
قطاع الطاقة يخبرني الرئيس التنفيذي لورنزو سيمونيلي
المزيد عن هذه الفكرة الكبيرة
الشيء المهم التالي في صناعة الطاقة
هو تقليل
الانبعاثات وليس مصادر الوقود
وهذه هي التكنولوجيا التي نركز
عليها في شركة بيكر هيوز كشركة لتكنولوجيا الطاقة ،
لذلك دعونا نتحدث عن
التقنيات المثيرة التي
تنشرها في مجال الروبوتات وتقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي
حسنًا ،
كيف سيساعد ذلك الشركات على
أن تصبح أكثر استدامة ،
سأمنحك شارعًا مثيرًا للاهتمام  إذا قمت فقط بجعل
الصناعة 10 أكثر كفاءة من خلال نشر
التقنيات التي ننتجها مثل
flare iq ، فيمكنك في الواقع تقليل نصف
جيجا طن من انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون
وهذا يمثل خمسة بالمائة من الهدف
نحو اتفاقية باريس أريد التحدث
عن
الذكاء لأنني أممم  نرى الكثير من
حرق الغاز كيف تحل هذه المشكلة
لأنك أولاً تهدر الغاز بشكل
صحيح وثانيًا إنه أمر سيء حقًا
للبيئة حيث تهدر الغاز وهو
عار كبير ولذا قمنا بتطوير
تقنية تسمى flare iq
و  إذا نظرت إلى كومة مضيئة ، فإنها تعمل
بكفاءة تبلغ حوالي 70 ،
مما يعني أن لديك انبعاثات يتم
اشتعالها وتتزايد 30 من
خلال نشر flare iq ، فنحن قادرون على
زيادة كفاءة هذا المكدس
من 70 إلى 98
من حيث  الدول الأكثر نضجًا
المنتجة للنفط تحديدًا في
الشرق الأوسط ، ما هو نوع الطلب الذي
تراه أعني ، ما هو نوع
المحادثات التي تجريها خلف
الأبواب المغلقة ، حيث يوجد عدد من
الشركات الكبرى  في مجموعات الهيدروجين ،
إنهم يبحثون في طريقة
تطوير cc لنا ، فهم في الواقع
يزيلون الاحتراق ، لذلك هناك الكثير من
النشاط وأعتقد أيضًا
أنك سمعت خلال هذا المؤتمر المزيد والمزيد
عن كيفية تقدم الشركات إلى الأمام
وأيضًا  يعتبر النقل من الفحم إلى
الغاز
الطبيعي الغاز الطبيعي إحدى الطرق التي
يمكننا من خلالها التحول ، ولكنه أيضًا
وقود مقصود ونحن متفائلون جدًا
بتوقعات الغاز